quotidien notre esprit est constamment
encombré par des doutes des
questionnements des inquiétudes ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des pensées parasites
et c'est pour ces parasites nous
empêchent de trouver la tranquillité
elle nous empêche de trouver la paix
intérieure ce que les stoïciens
appelaient l'ataraxie l'absence de
troubles et le problème n'est pas tant
le fait que dépenser nous traversent le
problème est que ces pensées portent le
plus souvent sur des choses qui ne
dépendent pas de nous ou qui n'en
dépendent plus on s'inquiète de
l'entretien d'embauche qu'on vient de
passer parce qu'on n'est pas sûr d'avoir
donné les bonnes réponses à l'employeur
alors on stresse on s’angoisse on se met
la pression sauf que à partir du moment
où on est sorti du bureau de l'employeur
la suite ne dépend plus de nous
comprendre que ce qui ne dépend pas de
nous ne débrons pas de nous c'est
comprendre que nous devons abandonner
notre désir de tout contrôler pour nous
concentrer uniquement sur ce qui dépend
de nous
[Musique]